anyway our next presenters are not just
talented but in the event of a nuclear
holocaust I would like them to
repopulate the earth
ladies and gentlemen Jessica Alba and
Eric Bana
so imagine you're in a room with four
gorgeous girls standing in front of you
each one trying her best to get your
attention or if you prefer four gorgeous
guys well that's the task that faces the
sound mixer on a film
he's got voice tracks music tracks
ambient sound tracks and background
checks and he has to give each one the
attention it deserves it requires skill
and artistry and these the nominators
responsible for the auditory wonders
this year Terry Porter Dean aids of
hansik and Tony Johnson for The
Chronicles of Narnia The Lion the Witch
and the Wardrobe
Christopher boys Michael semanek Michael
Hedges and Hammond Peak for King Kong
Kevin O'Connell Greg P Russell Rick
Klein and john pritchett for Memoirs of
a Geisha Paul Massey diem Hemphill and
Peter F kerlun for walk the line Andy
Nelson Annabel Mer and Ronald judkins
for War of the Worlds and the Oscar goes
to
Christopher boys Michael semantics
Michael Hedges and having take the King
Kong
this is the second Academy Award for
Michael semanek Michael Hedges of MMP
and fourth Academy Award for Christopher
Boyles this sound mixing team took home
an Oscar for Lord of the Rings The
Return of the King oh there is we would
like to thank the Academy we would like
to thank the amazing filmmaker Peter
Jackson Carol Cunningham Jan blinken and
Fran Walsh and my mom Catherine I thank
my mother for giving me unconditional
support when I chose this crazy career
you questioned me only once you sure you
don't want to be a doctor
yes mom I'm sure I love you I'd like to
thank our men dysley amazing talented
crew back at pak roy posts and
wellington new zealand what a great job
to everyone my mother this is for you my
wife Joanne and my dear kids Stephen and
Lisa thank you to the rock that is my
family and to the great production sound
crew go Kiwis thank you here to present
a special award
please welcome
Nashville Lily Tomlin and the most
nominated actor in Oscar history 14-time
nominee Meryl Streep